STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
THE LEFT WORKED THEMSELVES
INTO HYSTERIC THIS WEEK WHEN
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD BE
THE ONE WHO DECIDES WHEN TO
OPEN AND HE WENT ON TO SAY
THAT HIS DECISION WOULD BE
MADE IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
STATES GOVERNORS BUT LEFT OUT
THAT INCONVENIENT FACTS GET IN
THE WAY OF THE NARRATIVE.
HE’S PROCLAIMED HIMSELF A
KING.
WHAT ABOUT THE TENTH
AMENDMENT.
IT’S OBVIOUS THEY HAVEN’T EVEN
READ THE TENTH AMENDMENT.
IF THEY DID THEY WOULD REALIZE
THEY’D HAVE TO THROW AWAY
ABOUT HALF THEIR PLATFORM.
HERE’S WHAT THE TENTH
AMENDMENT ACTUALLY SAYS.
THE POWER IS NOT DELEGATED TO
THE UNITED STATES BY THE
CONSTITUTION NOR PROHIBITED BY
IT.
OR RESERVED TO THE STATES
RESPECTIVELY OR TO THE
PEOPLE.
TAKE NOTE BIDEN, CUOMO AND THE
REST OF YOU ABOUT SIGNALING
TRUMP HATING ELITIST.
THAT MEANS.
[INAUDIBLE]
SO SAY GOODBYE TO YOUR PLAN TO
EXPAND OBAMACARE, YOUR PLANS
FOR FREE COLLAGEN TO MAKE BANK
ON MORTGAGES.
YOU USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
EXPAND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN A HUNDRED DIFFERENT WAYS
EVERY DAY.
NOW YOU’RE THE ONES LECTURING
US ABOUT THE TENTH AMENDMENT.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE RIGHT
THROUGH YOU.
WE HEAR ON THE SHOW ON THE
OTHER HAND TRULY BELIEVE IN